era un fiscal estrella el rostro de la
lucha contra la corrupción en corea del
sur el hombre que estuvo detrás de las
condenas de dos ex presidentes y del
jefe de samsung ahora y un su que hoy se
convertirá en el vigésimo presidente de
la cuarta economía de asia
el conservador planea reducir
drásticamente los impuestos sobre las
inversiones en acciones flexibilizar las
normas sobre las cripto monedas y
suavizar la regulación del mercado
inmobiliario así como ayudar a las
pequeñas empresas afectadas por la
pandemia en cuanto a corea del norte y
un quiere reanudar las conversaciones
pero también impulsar la disuasión
militar comprando otro sistema de
misiles sat a washington a pesar del
riesgo de represalias de china
para proteger la seguridad la propiedad
el territorio y la soberanía de la
población construiremos una fuerte
fuerza de defensa nacional que pueda
disuadir con seguridad cualquier
provocación
el líder entrante no es un feminista en
la víspera de las elecciones
el equipo de yun suk y all se retractó
de una declaración hecha al 'washington
post' en la que decía que se consideraba
a sí mismo como tal esto en el día
internacional de la mujer la igualdad de
género fue un tema candente durante la
campaña de 2022 y el equipo de yun se
dirigió al voto masculino joven uno que
se ha vuelto cada vez más hostil contra
los derechos de las mujeres y las
minorías el conservador ha prometido
abolir el ministerio de género y familia
y un se enfrenta a múltiples desafíos la
profundización de la desigualdad la tasa
de fertilidad más baja del mundo y los
precios inmobiliarios
aparentemente imparables en seúl